toujours ça le dimanche se tient la fête
semaine quand on s'arrête pour découvrir
une réalité très importante peut-être
méconnu au québec et au canada c'est la
réalité des jeunes proches aidants des
enfants des adolescents qui prennent
soin d'un membre de leur famille et donc
des enfants qui ont des conséquences
bien bien direct dans leur vie on pense
par exemple à l'école mais les libéraux
coordonnatrice générale du regroupement
des aidants naturels du québec est avec
moi pour en parler ce matin bonjour
madame pérou bonjour et si on en parle
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il ya un an
le premier symposium qui est organisée
cette semaine vendredi à montréal
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'on
peut le croire les jeunes prochaine mais
il représente à peu près un quart de la
population des 15 29 ans puis dans le
fond on n'a pas de statistiques pour les
moins de 15 ans fait qu'il serait
probablement plus nombreux qu'on pense
parce que ça peut commencer dès l'âge de
6 ans le sait vraiment pas une question
de de limite à 12 ans ou à 15 ans on
peut très tôt commencé à aider sa maman
ou un frère ou une soeur ou un grand
parent ce le cas donc 25 % des livres 16
à 29 ans je regardais également les
statistiques de 7,6 canada bon qui
remonte à 2012 mais on parlait de deux
millions de jeunes proches aidants dans
l'ensemble du pays
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on est un enfant ou un adolescent
proches aidants ça veut dire que dans le
fond on va à l'école puis quand on
revient de l'école au lieu de faire ses
devoirs au lieu d'aller au soccer ou
hockey ou à la danse bas on se met à
aider un membre de sa famille soit pour
des soins de santé réel soit pour gérer
toutes les autres tâches de la maison
qui peuvent pas être fait parce que le
parent malade ou le grand parent est
malade et que le parent prend soin de
cette de la personne malade fait qu'il
ait pas disponible pour le reste de la
famille pour le reste de la fratrie
mais qui est vraiment deux façons
différentes dettes reprocher dans puis
ça peut ça peut aller jusqu à régler des
affaires à la banque la main donc tout
est en ligne c'est assez facile on sait
pas qui est derrière l'écran en train de
faire des virements
en train de gérer ce genre d'affaires là
ça peut aller à des soins de santé quand
même assez assez important où il ya des
professionnels qui ont des diplômes pour
ça il ya des jeunes et dans qui eux
apprennent sur le tas à prendre soin
d'eux d'une personne autour d'eux donc
c'est très très prenant dans la vie je
me dis que l'enfant l'adolescent jeunes
adultes fait face à toutes sortes de
difficultés aussi par la suite tout à
fait et des difficultés au niveau
scolaire parce qu'il ya un absentéisme
qui est plus grand il ya un manque de
concentration une fois qu'on est à
l'école fait qu'il ya c'est sûr que ça
joue sur le parcours scolaire les
opportunités aussi scolaire il ya des
difficultés aussi plus je dirais des
risques accrus d'anxiété des difficultés
aussi à rentrer en relation avec les
jeunes de son âge parce qu'on est comme
en décalage avec ce qu'on fait à la
maison ne suis pas les mêmes émissions
étaient les leurs ont dû s à ce moment
le mvuc restée exactement
puis il ya eu aussi une grande peur
surtout quand c'est les parents dans le
fond qui ont une maladie c'est la peur
que ça se découvre puis que le système
rentrer dans l'âme et dans la famille
puis la disloque parce que dans le fond
le parent n'est pas disponible à
l'enfant fait que c'est pas bon pour
l'enfant fait qu'on va le placer dans
une autre famille fait que ça isole
énormément ces jeunes a oui donc souvent
on essaie de cacher un peu cette visite
est là aux autorités on essaie de le
cacher aux autorités puis on le système
éducatif actuellement a pas de mots pour
décrire ça il ya beaucoup de
d'enseignants qui disent ah oui je sais
il prend soin d'eux
mais on va pas se dire ah non mais c'est
pas juste une fois de temps en temps le
ça peut aller y en a 5 % qui font plus
que vingt heures par semaine puis à 5 %
des jeunes et donc font plus qu'une
personne à la fois fait que c'est quand
même un temps assez conséquents dans
leur vie un temps où les jeunes de leur
âge font autre chose de plus ludique qui
on va dire donc si le système ne se
connaît pas nécessairement la réalité il
n'ya pas nécessairement de soutien qui
qui qui est là pour pour ces jeunes
proches aidants ben non seulement
individuellement on connaît pas la
réalité de ces jeunes là mais en plus
collectivement c'est un sujet qui est
très peu traité au canada ça commence
depuis le début des années
mille au québec c'est le premier la
première fois qu'il ya quelque chose de
qui confère à ce niveau là et à d'autres
pays par contre ça fait plus que vingt
ans qu'ils ont mis en place des systèmes
en colonne en nouvelle angleterre par
exemple ils ont même une loi ou c'est
stipulé les jeunes et d'enfants qui sont
aidés ils ont dû soutien spécifique
ici on est encore très très loin de ça
puis c'est ça qu'on cherche à faire en
fait avec le symposium s'est placé
latapie trouvé vers où on s'envole pour
sensibiliser la population sensibilisée
milieu de l'éducation milieu de la santé
et les jeunes et dans le même donc c'est
toute la journée vendredi 22 mars de 9h
à 16 ans ça se passe dans
côte-des-neiges les gens peuvent
toujours s'inscrire pour laisser pourrir
reste quelques places mais pas beaucoup
on a vraiment eu beaucoup de
il ya eu comme un enthousiasmant sur sur
ça on a beaucoup de mondes différents
qui viennent du milieu scolaire du
milieu de la santé c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir l'impact que ça
eut bien espérons que ça donne les
résultats que vous escomptez un apéro
merci au revoir au revoir